hey guys it's Ryan right here and this
morning because it's morning and I woke
up really early so I could check this
trailer out it is of course the third
trailer for x-men Days of Future past
ruin we were young and we would just go
into shadows and point three fingers out
and we look like Wolverines claws
I was sweet I really want to watch this
trailer because I am so [ __ ] excited
for this I almost cried the last trailer
I saw for this movie it just looks that
good Bryan Singer's back one of the
coolest homosexuals ever I love how the
movie doesn't look like it's another
Wolverine film it looks like you know
they're really focusing on the in Samba
this time it looks like it's pretty more
attention to detail on 90 DOE and Xavier
then Wolverine I mean no remember I love
over rain I [ __ ] suck Hugh Jackman's
dick but I think Michael Fassbender has
a bigger penis you see the movie shame
that man has nothing to be ashamed about
so I'm gonna watch a new trailer and I'm
also gonna watch the opening battle
click as everyone has been telling me to
watch that as well so here goes nothing
let's get this show on the road
so we're going to start off with the
trailer
ah the imagery professor you're gonna
find this hard to believe I was sent
here for you from the future
50 years from now better eh adults give
me that one more time please
stay with me in the beginning Sentinels
were just targeting mutants then I began
targeting everyone oh [ __ ]
I've come a long way to guide us to
brings together the x-men nicely drill
tell whoever it was the sentries unbusy
the person who sent me what do you view
yeah
sir to all of us to end this war your
Beast
I don't know what you're talking about
pretty strong for a scrawny kid I said
you need to leave you and I are gonna be
good friends you just don't know it yet
this [ __ ] expert why you're cold
hurry
whoa back where's Magneto
that man is a monster he's being held a
hundred floors beneath the most heavily
guarded building on the chronic I know a
guy he'd be a young man
nice is a pain in the ass Prison Break
that's illegal you know alone if you get
caught that's the guy from American
Horror Story
Charles everyone's just punching each
other - old friend this is gonna be fun
to this movie looks so cool
there is a new enemy out there
you'll need a new weapon for this one
they look pretty scary
everything that happens now
yeah he's in your hands
whoa it's got the claws back
[ __ ] [ __ ] sentinels man
in the future I'm a kid no uh-uh
dude that movie looks [ __ ] awesome
dude that's gonna be the best movie of
the year hands down I'm declaring that
pit stop trailers alone that movie's
gonna [ __ ] rock it looks like it
actually has a really good story great
acting great directing and the actions
gonna deliver it looks like what summer
movies are all [ __ ] about man I
cannot wait for this movie oh dude it's
just right around the corner it's like a
month from now Wow okay yeah I'm jacked
up this is the best morning ever the
visuals haven't proved off damn dude and
Wolverine as a centerpiece connecting
the story it's it's gonna be sweet we're
gonna see a movie about Charles Magneto
and Wolverine as primary characters it
just looks like it has great overall
focus around the in Samba it doesn't
look like it's spreading itself too thin
I'm gonna see this [ __ ] film midnight
show all right now it's time for the
opening battle clip let's do this I
really hope they don't go all spider-man
2 on us and release a billion movie
clips but here goes nothing let's watch
what is about to be awesome [ __ ]
you
the things look better than I thought
they would be
whoa
damn she's hot that's one
to the [ __ ] action looks directed so
is so intense
how creepy
nice
sweet she's so hot when she wasn't gay
ah that's it it's the first time in a
long time resonate clear I'm like I want
to see way [ __ ] more dude just that
little tease is just it's like intense
the mood is just set just [ __ ] right
I just love a movie that knows how to
tell good character stories and also
[ __ ] deliver on action man Bryan
Singer is back way better than Jack the
giant slayer anyway guys if you're new
to this channel subscribe so we can
annoy you with emails every time a new
video is out of course it's time for the
shout outs people you set a Schroth this
dude one of our biggest fans love this
guy a lot dude I know I've been saying
over and over again that we're gonna
Skype maybe when I decide to actually
make time for it when I'm not so busy
where I you know can actually carve out
on my busy schedule for you then maybe
we can Skype but who knows maybe I just
want to get my nails done no man I'm
kidding what we'll Skype one day Michael
Voris the brother of Jason Voorhees I
think that's the Friday the 13th
character this dude he requested a shout
out so here it is you scary [ __ ]
gavin Reyes
this dude's at do your best to give me a
shout-out oh I'm trying
Gavin I'm trying maybe just maybe shout
you Gavin turn no Gino